- This is the... top.
Yep, this is the top. (laughs)
And, okay, yep, that's
the bottom. All right.
- I don't think I've ever
spent a dime on a bathing suit.
- And I know zero about
women's bathing suits.
- Muy caliente! Okay.
- A little Sports Illustrated action!
- That's not the front, is it?
How do women do it.
I would not feel okay with this.
- This is a large, are you kidding me?
This is two eye patches
that were sewn together.
(laughs) Look at this stupid thing.
- $150.
- Let's say $24 for the set.
- $34, that's how much it is.
- $200?
No!
- Okay, so this is a good price.
There's no way this is
$25 worth of material.
- See, this is nice, gotta
whole Boardwalk Empire vibe.
- There's a triangle right here.
Illuminati confirmed.
- $40.
- $75.
- Whaaat?
- Shut up, this is a $246 swimsuit.
- You're going into the ocean or into
a chlorine-filled pool,
and you're gonna spent
almost $300 on this?
Why don't you just go in your prom dress.
- You must look damn
good in this one-piece.
- Do you have to buy 'em separately?
Oh my gosh!
- This is an awesome color scheme.
- It's also kinda tacky.
I'd say probably 30 bucks.
- $29.
- $18.
- Whoa, a hundred and, $102.
- This is a $102 bottom?
- The more frills there are,
the more expensive it gets.
- The young lady who chooses this one
is a fan of peace.
- I'm looking at the
frilly part in the front,
it's fairly soft, $32.
- I'd say this probably
cost like, 40 bucks.
This maybe cost like 50 bucks.
- Okay, now we're in the
bargain deals right here.
This is cool, this is one
of my favorites so far.
And it's like cheap.
What is goin on here?
Do you like put it on like that?
- This is like an older,
distinguished woman's swimsuit.
- Probably my grandma would wear this.
- This is straight-up Taylor Swift.
- $85.
- $43.
- $35.
- I would never spent
$175 on a bathing suit.
Okay, like maybe if it lit up
or something cool. (laughs)
But these aren't lighting up!
Women, they have to mix and match,
they have to try to find a good deal,
they have to find cute ones.
Like, it's tough.
I mean, half the time I go
swimming in basketball shorts.
- You're beautiful the way you are.
These things, they're nice,
they're super nice, first off.
But expensive.
- If paying $100 makes you
feel better in your swimsuit,
then great.
Swimsuit manufacturers, shame on you.
- At first I was just like,
women are just getting screwed
by these swimsuit companies.
But now that I know there's
some affordable ones,
you probably have these
like seven different ones
for seven different days
in seven different colors.
I know I would.
- This is not a large.